talk about the big bang big bang being a
singularity you know a Hawking Penrose
Hawking hartle we talk about these
things but it seems like you need to
justify quantum gravity because there
could be these two regimes that are in
principle unobservable namely the core
of a black hole and the beginning of the
universe to what extent would you bet
your neighbor's pet ferrets life on the
existence of a singularity the only
thing that comes out of the Horizon is
talking radiation we don't see that
that's correct you see a black disc the
black discs and around the black disc
you see these rings of light those are
rings of Light which have been focused
by the gravity of black hole the black
disc itself the radius of the Blackness
is not something that has to do with the
singularity it's something that has to
do with the Horizon that black disc if
you like it's a size its properties are
the Horizon when you hear the ringing
noise and the gravitational radiation
coming from it that is pretty much
direct observation of the Horizon of the
black hole